the following is supplemental report 239
- B - 192 interviewed doctor a cliff
interview where dr. kondraki this
interview took place 24 hours after the
site 17 examined Condor our key clef
how's the leg I'll be fine our the face
the eyes dears an entire body they gave
me a few minutes with the pendant enough
to heal me not enough to turn me into
the blonde Shana might actually improve
your personality I've missed you too
how's the girl
comatose tears knocked her out on sight
after she did that thing with the dragon
it was better if she stayed that way
they locked her up in a room line with
Teleco who do they have assigned to
watch her bowel decision that poor girl
funny coming from the one who tried to
kill her I wasn't talking about the SCP
so why'd you do it you've read the
report haven't you there was a mistake
on my part I thought they could help
contain her but pardon me bull [ __ ]
according to the report you're an
absolute [ __ ] who screwed up so badly
that he caused a major site-wide
incident but if I know you you're not a
[ __ ] you're a sadistic evil and
conniving bastard but you're not stupid
I never knew you cared
cut the crap clef what are you really
after I have no idea what you're talking
about Connie dear it's all too
convenient
a parcel voice log from your PDA that
cuts
just as lilith manages to order you to
tell the truth an emergency call that
summons two other foundation researchers
on the scene a major security breach
that causes every single SCP at that
base to leave their containment cells
massive casualties including at least
two SCPs
one of which we had high hopes for one
of which you personally vouched for do
you watch cartoons gun dropping you
should check out this show called
gargoyles I think you'd like it
what the hell are you trying to do were
you trying to kill someone get in
contact with someone they can put the
girl asleep right it really is the
nature of my game that's puzzling you
isn't it what pleased to meet you hope
you guess my name oh [ __ ]
you're lying you always lie yes I do
always lie don't die
one might even call me the father of
lies considering all the lying I do
funny that women hate you
of course they do considering that
little incident with the apple tree I'm
not surprised they still Harbor some
lingering resentment that was all for
the best though
Lilith knew you she said you loved her
you said you never stopped loving him
she was too good for that simpering fool
untamed
strong and wild a true woman not that
whiny little submissive [ __ ] Eve of
course that milquetoast ass all prefer
the one who would lie quietly and take
it not the one who would actually show
them at the wood-nymph you confessed to
the flower apple blossoms if you look
closely enough at sooner Rose also known
as the Alpha and Omega the great I am
I'm still not sure what she's doing
incarnate in again I mean it basically
means heaven is empty right now and my
people are gonna be storming the gates
anytime soon my god is currently lying
in a coma in a hospital bed nearby yeah
helpless alone completely vulnerable
oh Jesus Christ you're actually buying
this [ __ ] aren't you Oh God look on
your face it's priceless it's better
when I told gears that Alice had hacked
my optics and convinced me to get rid of
the competition you really put that
little monster through the amour I had
to check for infection in her brain
before he figured out it was
bullshitting him but he'll that frigid
bastards got no voices at all that's not
nearly as [ __ ] hilarious as you lying
son of a [ __ ] and here's a really
fucked-up part and Draghi what if I'm
lying right now
what if I did just tell you the truth
before and what you primitive Apes call
heaven is currently laying wide open
ready to be stormed by my followers what
if you die and your soul crosses the
boundary and you find those damned art
Emma site gates covered with the bloody
wings of Elohim nailed to the walls and
want to find they're ready to lead you
to your eternal reward and what if I've
got and I'm showing her all the things
that you'll never you bastard I'll kill
you you'll never unfit Connie it'll
always be back there in the back of your
head nagging nagging tickling you
spinning you around in an unending
spiral it is determined that this is the
point where dr. cliff accidentally fell
out of his chair and struck his head
nine times against the corner of the
desk fracturing his skull and snapping
his neck between the second and third
vertebrae dr. clef remains in intensive
care
paralyzed from the neck down dr.
kondraki has been cleared of all
responsibility regarding the incident